how are you doing today sir
i'm very good now that i'm talking to
you how are you
that's very nice for you to say we're
doing excellent we're going to start
with backgrounds i love the background i
literally made this for you
so cool
um i i have to start with uh i checked
out your instagram uh last night when i
was researching getting ready to talk to
you and there's this amazing photo of
you with the dutch giant
where because you're an enorm you're a
very large man he is
another level what was it i mean what is
it like standing next to someone like
that when you're already
a very large person
probably the same feeling that simu has
when he stands next to me
just joking i mean
well that's
that guy's first of all he's super sweet
but
yeah he's he seems like super natural
and
well yeah let's talk about shanghai
sure uh which of your friends and family
were the most excited that you were
getting to be in a marvel movie
all of them i mean
you know uh my parents always i the best
relationship with my parents they're my
biggest supporters
and then my friends my inner circle that
i call my brothers you know when i
am successful or i'm hitting a new
project they all are
happy for me in a way like they would
earn you know that success
so um
everyone was super excited
just also because everyone knew that
it was a long-term goal of mine to to
get into the mcu
i just thought that it would take me a
little bit longer but here we are now
so
i would imagine you had a lot of
thoughts going when you were getting
ready to film like what is this going to
be like what surprised you about making
chungchi that perhaps you weren't
expecting well you know
prior to this project everyone was
telling me what they wanted to create in
terms of the fighting
because
you know
this movie is very important like this
movie had to deliver because
it's so important for you know diversity
and the asian community
and because it's so martial arts
inspired everyone was talking prior to
that project how
crazy big and epic they wanted to
deliver
the the fighting sequences and i was
very
skeptical in the beginning
just because
um
i heard it so many times that you know
people want to create this and that
so i'm always very careful with the
with things like that when i hear them
prior going into a project
and then i i was i was stepping into the
project working with the stunt team
and i knew from the very first beginning
okay they were not lying they're really
really serious about it and i saw stuff
i've never seen before
they taught me stuff
i thought you know
i could never learn and they definitely
not from a fighting perspective and from
a martial arts perspective they
definitely made me a better fighter as
well and i feel like
um
the goal what they had
prior to the movie i think they deliver
big time i think the fighting sequences
are happening
i 100 agree before i run out of time
with you i am very excited for the
borderlands movie uh very i want to
stress the word very excited what can
you tease people about the
about the film because i've heard that
the sets are straight out of the video
game
so i feel like people are craving for a
good um
a game a good game adaption because
usually if they if they make um
if they take a game and want to make a
movie out of it they usually fail
it never delivered the big
in a big way and i feel like this time
you know the director and everyone
around the team created something
incredible and i'm not i'm not just
saying that because i'm in this movie
but everyone was
so eager to
uh create something they were really
working with the fans these times
and well you got to be in you but you
got to wait for it and see but i can
promise you you won't be disappointed
i've i've heard listen congrats on
everything that's going on in your
career i wish you nothing but the best
thank you my friend